that's not the plan
it's crazy because you mentioned Pitbull
earlier and like I remember when Pitbull
first came out
he was like rapping like like he had a
song I still have old pitbull records
well he he had he had a um he had a song
with nas that never I don't think got
dropped but it was like a Napster called
imagine it was like sampling like John
Lennon so far but it's so crazy to see
like I'm guessing they couldn't clear
that I'm assuming not right but like did
you like being around Pitbull so early
did you have any inclination that like
he would end up being such a worldwide
Superstar like when you Google pitbull
the dog doesn't even come up when you
Google Pitbull that's funny he comes up
first it's it's just it's like at least
he spelled it correctly that's how
famous he is like ludicrous and fabulous
I can't spell the words it's not like
the rapper yeah how do you spell
ludicrous yeah I mean Pitbull was he was
always just a hustler like in certain
people you know when you see that work
ethic you're like they're I mean they're
gonna make it and I was a fan of the
music like I remember hearing him I was
driving over the causeway like four
o'clock in the morning leaving the beach
and he was on the radio freestyling or
maybe it was recorded I don't know but
like welcome to Miami you know just yeah
freestyle out and um I was like this is
I where can I find this like how can I
find this rapper and um as soon as I met
him I was like yeah he's you know he's
gonna make it because he's I've told
this story before I was supposed to
interview another artist who was uh I
want to say he was signed to
Jive another artist he just got like a
big label deal and it was like all over
the radio like this is the next big
thing from Miami and I'm waiting waiting
waiting for him to show up I think he
was it was like the second time and he
just didn't show up and I was on a
deadline and I'm like what am I going to
put in this magazine I have these pages
I got to turn in right and uh Pitbull's
manager at the time big teach was like
in their our adjoining office we were on
this like music industry kind of central
office in downtown Miami and um I go
over and say hey teach like how quick
could Pitbull get here I gotta get this
you know turned in the printer and pit
was like oh I'll be there in 10 minutes
and right we went downstairs did a photo
shoot on the beach which incidentally
that photo is in the Smithsonian now
which is crazy or it's it's part of the
Smithsonian Collection wow
um and we did an interview and
sounded depressed and so to me if you're
an artist and you're trying to get on
like that's the attitude that's the
attitude to have like you got to be you
know if you need somebody to come drop a
freestyle like listen that just happened
I just had Jadakiss at my table and this
kid from Phoenix has amazing rapper
Markham snuck his way into the BT media
room so he was telling me how much he I
was like who do you like this up and
companies I mean I just like that real
rap so I like I was like go get miracles
so I had him a mic and he freestyle for
Jadakiss and killed it it was it was
dope that's what it takes you know for
sure 100 no it's crazy because like I
think like back then there was ozone and
then I feel like the West Coast we kind
of had like murder dogs yeah murder dog
was like they were like a little more
grimier than they were grimy as [__]
murder dog was crazy
um and it was almost like murder dog but
I feel like I I was trying to make an
effort to be like a little more
I don't want to say mainstream but yeah
when your magazines a little more
polished maybe yes 100
I was real serious about the the
editing like typos and the presentation
of it I wanted even if the subject
matter was like Street and right like
authentic I wanted to like look a
certain